اخبار العالم بانجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
انها تخوض حرب شوارع شمال باخموت وتسعى
للسيطره على اخر معاقل الجيش الاوكراني في
المدينه زيلينسكي يتعهدوا باستمرار الدفاع
عن المدينه ويعلن دعم ميزانيه جيشه بثلاثه
عشر مليار دولار وبوتين يقول ان الصراع في
اوكرانيا بالنسبه لروسيا هو للحفاظ على
وجودها كدوله
الكنيست الاسرائيليه صادق بالقراءه الاولى
على احد اهم التعديلات التي اقترحتها
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو على النظام القضائي
في اسرائيل والذي يتيح للكنيست التغلب على
قرارات المحكمه العليا كما صادق على مشروع
قانون اخر يمنع تنحيه رئيس الحكومه من
منصبه الا وفق اسباب نفسيه او مرضيه
انصار رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان يشتبكون مع الشرطه المحليه خارج
منزله اثناء محاوله اعتقاله للمره الثانيه
وزير الداخليه يقول انه سيتم اعتقاله
عمران خان اليوم وتقديمه للمحاكمه في
المقابل طالب اخان في كلمه انصاره بمواصله
التظاهر لنيل ما وصفه بالحريه والاستقلال
حتى لو تم اعتقاله
مسجله مئه الف ليره للدولار الواحد الليره
اللبنانيه تتراجع لمستوى قياسي غير مسبوق
امام الدولار في السوق الموازيه وتزامن
ذلك مع بدء المصارف اللبنانيه اضرابا
مفتوحا عن العمل لاحتجاجا على قرارات
قضائيه تلزمها بتسديد ودائعه بالعملات
الاجنبيه
الى اللقاء